hagamos otro problema de este cometería
donde la reacción se esté llevando a
cabo en una solución dice nuestro
problema 5 metálico reacciona con ácido
clorhídrico en solución acuosa y aquí
nos dan nuestra reacción que al parecer
ya está balanceada pero vamos a
verificarlo más adelante nos dice que el
zinc reacciona el zinc reacciona con el
ácido clorhídrico verdad para producir
esta sal más hidrógeno gaseoso que
volumen de 2.5 molar el cloro es persona
ácido clorhídrico en mililitros se
requieren para convertir completamente
11.8 gramos de zinc en los productos muy
bien entonces lo que vamos a hacer es lo
siguiente vamos a iniciar con nuestros
11.8 gramos de zinc de hecho déjenme ir
marcando estos tenemos esta esta
concentración o más bien tenemos esta
solución de ácido clorhídrico en esta
concentración
nos piden dar la respuesta en mililitros
pero lo con lo que vamos a partir es con
11.8 gramos d
muy bien entonces partimos de estos 11.8
gramos de zinc y lo que necesitamos es
ver cuántos moles se necesitan para
llevar a cabo esta reacción con estos 11
puntos 8 gramos de zinc muy bien
entonces si ya digamos suponiendo que ya
vimos que está balanceada de esta
ecuación y que si está solo vamos a
verificar lo más adelante entonces por
cada molde zinc necesitamos dos moles de
ácido clorhídrico muy bien entonces
fácilmente podríamos ver cuántos moles
de ácido clorhídrico necesitamos y
finalmente convertir todo esto a los
mililitros que nos que nos piden ya que
sabemos cuál es la concentración de esta
solución muy bien entonces ese es el
plan de acción quizás parece muy muy muy
complicado pero vas a ver que mientras
lo vamos haciendo en realidad es muy
fácil ok entonces vamos a iniciar
tenemos nuestros 11 puntos 8 gramos de
zinc
nuestros 11.8 gramos de zinc y queremos
ver cuántos moles son así que
multiplicamos por algo que abajo tenga
gramos de zinc y arriba tenga moles de
zinc que entonces nos preguntamos
cuántos gramos de zinc hay en cada mol
entonces por cada molde zinc uno puede
verificar en una tabla periódica la que
tú quieras que cada molde zinc tiene 65
punto 38 gramos de zinc muy bien
entonces antes de pasar con la
calculadora y demás en realidad voy a
dejar esas matemáticas para el final
pero lo importante aquí es que los
gramos de zinc se cancelan y simplemente
nos quedamos nos quedamos con 11.8 11.8
divididos entre 65 punto 38 moles de
zinc muy bien entonces ya obtuvimos el
número de moles que estas reacciones o
bueno tiene
a llevar así que esta reacción tiene
para llevarse a cabo ahora lo que
necesitamos es ver cuántos moles de
ácido clorhídrico se requieren y eso
también es muy fácil por lo siguiente
por cada molde zinc por cada molde cinc
aquí no se está diciendo cada molde zinc
necesitamos nosotros 22 moles de ácido
clorhídrico verdad esto está
directamente desde la reacción por cada
molde zinc
necesitamos dos moles de ácido
clorhídrico muy bien y esto es muy muy
muy bueno porque ya podemos otra vez
cancelar los moles de zinc y sólo
quedarnos con los moles de ácido
clorhídrico que necesitamos entonces
esto simplemente será 11.8 por 2 por 2
entre entre 65 punto 38 moles de ácido
clorhídrico muy bien si quieren déjenme
ponerlo así para que se entienda que es
una multiplicación muy bien
entonces este es el número de moles de
ácido clorhídrico requeridos muy bien
entonces aún no hemos resuelto el
problema porque no nos piden cuántos
moles nos piden cuántos mililitros de
esta solución muy bien entonces vamos a
pasar lo primero a litros vamos a pasar
lo primero a litros porque molar cuando
uno tiene aquí dos puntos sin como lar
en realidad nos está diciendo moles por
litro verdad entonces si no nos ponemos
a pensar en esto podemos multiplicar por
lo siguiente tenemos moles de ácido
clorhídrico nos dice tenemos 2.5 moles
de ácido clorhídrico por cada litro de
esta concentración es decir por cada
litro del 2.50 molar y si drop ácido
clorhídrico muy bien entonces no espero
que no te confunda esto esto esto de
aquí el 2.5 o 2.50 molar de ácido
clorhídrico es sólo un nombre para decir
que aquí tenemos una solución es una
solución que tiene 2.5
de ácido clorhídrico por litro entonces
esto justamente nos está diciendo que
tenemos 2.50 moles de ácido clorhídrico
por cada litro de esta de esta solución
muy bien entonces este este insisto es
sólo un nombre para ponerle a esa
solución muy bien entonces qué es lo que
obtenemos lo que obtenemos aquí es que
los moles de ácido clorhídrico se
cancelan muy bien y simplemente nos
quedan 11.8
esto es 11.8
y falta multiplicar por 2 por supuesto
multiplicado por 2 y dividido entre 65
punto 38 múltiple y multiplicamos por
2.50 muy bien 2.50 y de esto tenemos
litros de nuestra solución es decir de
la solución que se llama 2.50 molar de
ácido clorhídrico muy bien muy bien
entonces ahora ya casi acabamos sólo que
no nos preguntan cuántos mililitros
tenemos nos perdón nos preguntan cuántos
litros más bien nos preguntan cuántos
mililitros
necesitamos muy bien aquí estamos en
litros así que esto déjenme copiarlo
y seguir un poquito más abajo ok
entonces lo copiamos y seguimos un
poquito más abajo ahí lo tienen entonces
vamos a convertir esto último en
mililitros y eso es muy sencillo esto es
muy sencillo porque podemos multiplicar
aquí
algo que aquí tenga litros litros y
arriba mililitros simplemente pensemos
cuántos mililitros hay en cada litro
pues hay mililitros por cada litro
verdad entonces se cancelan los litros y
simplemente me quedan mililitros muy
bien entonces ya para terminar esto nos
queda 11.8 que multiplica a 2 que
multiplica a mil mil y dividimos todo
esto entre 65 punto 38 y nos falta y
aquí falta multiplicar por 2.50 y con
que es con lo que nos quedamos pues
justamente con los mililitros de 2.50
2.50 molar de h de ácido clorhídrico
requeridos muy bien entonces ahora si es
buen momento para sacar la calculadora
ok vamos a sacar la calculadora y
hagamos estas operaciones entonces
tenemos 11.8 que multiplica a dos y
luego multiplica a mil key y eso hay que
dividirlo entre 65 punto 38 si lo puse
bien ok y luego dividimos otra vez entre
2.50 muy bien y eso nos da 144 punto 38
vamos a dejarlo solo en 144 muy bien
entonces esto nos da simplemente 144
mililitros de nuestra solución que la
solución se llama 2.50 molar de ácido
clorhídrico y hemos terminado espero que
te hayas divertido